khung Skull Island of Kong we have a new
trailer for Kong Skull Island I just
realized this is a lot of blue I should
probably turn the background to red he's
usually blue when I talking about
trailers but blue overload right now
we'll see what I do so this your trailer
for Kong Skull Island we see that it
actually has a bit of humor in it this
military group goes to this island they
start dropping bombs and they're like is
that a big monkey and Kong just takes
their helicopters beats the [ __ ] out of
them I do like that shot where like
everything lines up you see comes face
reminded me of one of those uncharted
puzzles so Jon see Riley's like don't
worry these guys are gonna kill you
they're cool Kong he's King here he's a
good King usually but he started
dropping bombs in his backyard now he's
pissed which completely makes sense if
some stranger wandered into my yard and
started pissing on it and [ __ ] on
every like um you need to go tongs more
action than words though so he wouldn't
say anything let's just crush your
helicopters but we see what we all
imagined would happen is there are
monsters in this movie King Kong in this
movie's enormous this is not the big ape
that had a crush on Naomi Watts it's not
the same no this dude's a huge he walks
upright he is tromping around I've seen
him
compared to mountains in this trailer
and poster so you need monsters from
defy is not gonna fight the human beings
even if the human beings wanted to fight
King Kong what's he good it would be as
exciting as me taking a can of raid
sprang ants in my house it's not
exciting because it's that easy for him
so there's this big hole pretty much
goes to proverbial hell I guess it's a
big hole in the earth where monsters
live and Kong is gonna fight that boning
up for his big fight against Godzilla
there is humor in this trailer I want
them to use it sparingly I imagine they
will use it sparingly I mean the fact
that those humor in this trailer john c
reilly is humorous
is not to say the movies going to have
too much humour if you get a group
together there's going to be someone in
there that is humorous so it's just
always realistic to me to have someone
and have hugh moreno humour and banter
is gonna go back and forth no matter how
treacherous the situation generally
speaking i understand there's not a lot
of humor in Schindler's List it doesn't
really call for chasing down
mountainsides king kong yeah give us a
meal I'm looking forward to this one
just looks grand in scope huge in
execution and his King Kong Kong is
going to fight monsters and we're in the
middle of it ever boning up for that
Godzilla King Kong fight to the death
that we all just love Godzilla versus
King Congress is when I was a kid I used
to get the little books over these books
there were old monster movie books in
there those Godzilla King Kong Godzilla
versus King Kong so I feel like my
third-grade me gets to experience that
thing that I read about so long ago Kong
Skull Island is a cool trailer we see
some cool stuff we see King Kong in a
different light he's not there to
destroy I mean he throws a palm tree
through a helicopter he's a bad guy I
guess he's a pretty good King he just
came to his backyard start acting like
dick so he reacted and I like that turn
I like that take I like that element so
the Kong Skull Island trailer have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more